in the previous video you've already
seen all the basic building blocks of
the inception Network in this video
let's see how you can put these building
blocks together to build your own
inception network so the inception
module takes as input the activation or
the output from some previous layer so
let's say for the sake of argument this
is 28 by 28 by 192 same as our previous
video the example we work through in
Jeff was the 1 by 1 followed by five by
five they are so maybe the one by one
has 16 channels and then the 5 by 5 will
output a 28 by 28 by let's say 32
channels and this was the example we
were through on the last slide of the
previous video then to save computation
on your 3x3 convolution you can also do
the same here and then the 3 by 3
outputs 28 by 28 by 128 and then maybe
you want to consider a 1 by 1
convolution as well there's no need to
do a 1 by 1 comma followed by another 1
by 1 4 comma so that's just one step
here and let's say this outputs 28 by 28
by 64 and then finally is the pooling
layer so here I'm going to do something
funny in order together to concatenate
all of these outputs at the end we are
going to use a same type of having for
pooling so that the output height and
width is still 28 by 28 so we can
concatenate it with these other outputs
but notice that if you do max pooling
even with same padding 3 by 3 filter is
rather 1 the output here will be 28 by
28 by 192 it will have the same number
of channels on the same def as the input
that we have here so this seems like is
has a lot of channels so what we're
going to do is actually add one more one
by one con flare to then do what we saw
in the one by one convolutional video to
shrink the number of channels so as to
get this down to twenty by twenty eight
by let's say thirty two and the way you
do that is you use thirty two filters of
dimension one by one by one ninety two
so that's why the output dimension has a
number channels shrunk down to thirty
two so then you don't end up with the
pooling layer taking up all the channels
in the final output and finally you take
these all of these blocks and you do
channel concatenation just concatenate
across this 64 plus 128 plus 32 plus 32
and this if you had it up this gives you
a 28 by 28 by two five six dimensional
output ranch and from cadiz just you
know this concatenating the blocks that
we saw in the previous video so this is
one inception module and what the
inception network does is more or less
put a lot of these modules together
here's a picture of the inception
network taken from the paper by Zebedee
at all and you notice a lot of repeated
blocks in this maybe this picture looks
really complicated we've looked at one
of the blocks there that block is
basically the inception module that you
saw on the previous line and subject to
little details I won't discuss you know
this is another inception block this is
another inception block there's some
extra max pooling layers here take
the dimension of the height and width
but that's another inception block and
then there's another max put here to
change the height and width but
basically there's another inception
block but the inception network is just
a lot of these blocks that you've
learned about repeated to different
positions of the network but so if you
understand the inception block from the
previous slide then you understand the
inception network them it turns out that
there's one last detail to the inception
Network if you read the original
research paper which is that there are
these additional side branches that I
just added so what do they do well the
last few layers of the network is a
fully connected layer followed by a
softmax layer to try to make a
prediction what these side branches do
is it takes some hidden layer and it
tries to use that to make a prediction
so this is at your softmax output and so
is that and this other side branch again
takes a hidden layer passes it through
you know a few layers like a few fully
connected layers and then has the
softmax try to predict what's the output
label and you should think of this as
maybe just another detail of the
inception Network but what it does is it
helps to ensure that the features
computer even in the hidden units even
at the intermediate layers that they're
not too bad for predicting the output
cause of a image and this attempt
disappears to have a regular izing
effect on the inception Network and how
to prevent this network from overfitting
oh and by the way this particular
inception network was developed by
authors at Google who called it Google
net spelled like that to pay homage to
the lenient network that you learned
about in an earlier video as well so I
think is actually really nice that the
deep learning community is so
collaborative
there's such strong healthy respect for
each others were in the deep learning
community
finally here's one fun fact where does
the name inception Network come from the
inception paper actually cites this mean
for we need to go deeper and this URL is
an actual reference in the inception
paper which links to this image and if
you've seen the movie titled the
inception
maybe this mean will make sense to you
but the authors actually cite this meme
as motivation for needing to build
deeper neural networks and that's how
they came up with the inception
architecture so because it's not often
that research papers get to cite
internet memes in their citations but in
this case I guess it worked out quite
well so to summarize if you understand
the inception module then you understand
the inception Network which is largely
the inception module repeated a bunch of
times throughout the network since the
development of the original inception
module the authors and others have built
on it and come up with other versions as
well so their research papers on newer
versions of the inception algorithm and
you sometimes see people use some of
these later versions as well in their
work like Inception v2 Inception v3
Inception v4 there's also an inception
version this combined with the resident
idea of having skipped connections and
that sometimes works even better but all
of these variations are built on the
basic idea that you learned about in
this in the previous video of coming up
with the inception module and then
stacking up a bunch of them together and
with these videos you should be able to
read and understand I think the
inception paper as well as maybe some of
the papers describing the later
variations as well so that's it you've
gone through quite a lot of specialized
neural network architectures in the next
video I want to start showing you some
more practical advice on how to actually
use these algorithms to build your own
computer vision system
let's go onto the next video